[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous interdisons les importations de
pétrole et de gaz russe nous ne
financerons pas la guerre de beauty le
défi c'est l'hiver 2022 2023 c'est de là
que il pourrait y avoir des difficultés
c'est ces difficultés là que nous
voulons anticiper en portant cette idée
de stockage à 90% l'allemagne qui reçoit
60% de gaz russe est la plus exposée le
ministre de l'économie a fait savoir
qu'il ne fallait pas trop tirer sur la
corde
je me pose un embargo sur le gaz en
agissant ainsi nous mettons en danger la
cohésion sociale dans le pays la
finlande elle dépend à 100 % il fait des
températures négatives en ce moment en
finlande je pense qu on a déjà fait
beaucoup
comme le dit bruno le maire nous sommes
en train de réfléchir à faire encore
plus je suis le seul président du 21e
siècle si lequel la russie n'a envahi
aucun territoire
c'était pas brillant avant l'invasion
non plus un pays qui est
très très très très peu
malheureusement pillée par des
oligarques aussi là bas je suis toujours
à kiev ruban kova je ne me cache pas
et je n'ai peur de personne
le problème c'est pas que poutine son
intelligence parce qu'il est intelligent
dans le vrai problème c'est que nos
dirigeants sont des
manuels macro comme d'ailleurs madame
merkel puisqu'elle est au pouvoir
auparavant comme les américains ont fait
une grave erreur en maintenant l'idée
que l'ukraine pourrait éventuellement
rentrer dans le top savez la fameuse
clause de la porte ouverte à l'équipage
va redescendre sur terre avec un
américain et deux russes quel est votre
accueil de l'américain comment vont se
faire les prochaines remontée l'équipage
à bord du soyouz tout ça c'est des
points d'interrogation depuis ce soir on
connaît leur patrimoine celui qu'ils ont
déclaré à la haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique un peu
c'est valérie pécresse avec un
patrimoine de 9,7 millions d'euros deux
jours avant le lancement de la fusée
soyouz à kourou guyane qui lançait des
satellites de télécommunications pour
internet totalement les rues sont
déterminés
puis de lancement on ajoute les
lancements et le personnel russe rentrer
aussi je ne ferai pas de débat avec les
autres candidats avant le premier tour
aucun président en fonction qui se
représentaient ne l'a fait je ne vois
pas pourquoi je ferais différemment du
général de gaulle de françois mitterrand
très bien qu'ils ne débattent pas avant
le premier tour moi j'estime que il doit
c'est une façon un peu de ce défilé mais
il a trouvé l'argument comme si le paris
saint-germain décidée l'année suivante
ne pas faire les matches aller
ça c'est qu'on croit en nos trucs voilà
bah je décide de commencer là et ouais
c'est une manière de beille ça relève
d'un mépris quand même on a eu un
quinquennat de démocratie confisquée il
a dirigé le pays dans des conseils de
défense maîtrise méprisant les maires
enfin tout ça et du théâtre c'est pas de
la politique c'est du théâtre ça a été
organisé tout le monde avait sa fiche à
la virgule près c'est simon le baron de
france inter qui a trouvé des fiches qui
étaient donnés à monsieur macro et du
président obama chez olive et où il y
avait des affiches la photo la question
avait été écrite avant mais la question
carrément premières annonces pour doper
le pouvoir d'achat défense
on supprimera des impôts qui reste la
redevance télé en fait partie la
redevance elle finance quoi elle finance
le service public lui il va encore
prendre de l'argent dans la dette est
dans le déficit budgétaire moi je suis
cohérent je supprime une taxe pour les
français mais je supprime aussi le coup
le président de la république et trouver
un terrain d'entente avec l'extrême
droite sur la redevance télé sans dit
long sur la vision qu'il a du service
public